[Müzik]
hepinize merhaba öncelikle beni buraya
davet ederek bu anlamlı etkinliğin bir
parçası haline getirdikleri için tüm
organizasyon komitesine şükranlarımı
sunuyorum ama en büyük teşekkür akşamın
bu saatine kadar kalıp dinleyen ve
öğrenmenin Zihni yoran değil geliştiren
bir aktivite olduğunu düşünen sizlere
çok teşekkür ediyorum bu saate kadar al
Gerçekten çok değerli ve Enteresan olan
şey şu Yani ben hiç aklımda yoktu ama
burada son konuşmacı olduğumu öğrendim
ve her zaman son konuşmacı olduğumu
öğrendiğimde kendi yaşantımdan birtakım
kesitler aklıma gelir ama bugün herhalde
ikinci kez bunu söyleyeceğim kendi
konuşmamdan kesmek pahasına biraz
kısaltmak pahasına Çünkü Ne konuşacağımı
bilmiyorum slaytları getirdim ama
konuşuruz Ama şunu söylemek istiyorum
çok seneler Evveli bayağı seneler evvel
ve ben o zaman İngiltere'de bizim alan
dediğimiz kanıta dayalı yaklaşımlardan
bir tanesi burada psikolog olan
arkadaşlarım Neyi kastettiğimi bilirler
bu alanla ilgili neredeyse Devrim
sayılabilecek bir araştırma yapıyoruz
çok uluslu bir araştırma Amerikalılar
var kanadalılar var ve İngiltere
ekibinin terapis olarak da ben
çalışıyorum bu çalışma İngiltere'de
yapılan bir çalışma ama ü bacaklı bir
çalışma Yani aynı çalışmayı Amerika ve
Kanada'da yapıyor sonuçları da gerçekten
bilim dünyasını etkileyebilecek kadar
değerli bir çalışma Nitekim etkiledi ve
o zaman ismini kitaplardan Okudum ve çok
beğendiğim henüz Türkiye'de böyle bir
yaklaşım olmayan ve bu alanı temsil eden
bir Hocanın yanında
çalışıyorum yine de anayım Profesör
isaac Marx Eskiden ona bana isac
derlerdi hiç diyemezdim şimdi dostum çok
yaşlandı Hatta Her gittiğimde onu
görüyorum Her gittiğimde onu gördüğümde
de bir miktar kendi geleceğimi Tabii ki
görüyorum ve gerçekten sert bir hocaydı
bizim zamanımızda hocaların hepsi çok
sertti 3 kattan bağırdıkları zaman 5
kattaki hastalar hazır ola geçerdi falan
filan şimdiki hocalar öyle değil daha
yumuşak ya da Eskiler kadar işini
ciddiye almıyor hangisini isterseniz
şimdi o
dönemde dediler ki bu çalışmanın
sonuçlarını Hoca Sen sunacaksın dedim ki
ya hani ben sunarım ama Kanada Amerika
İngiltere Üstelik ben İngiltere'nin Türk
terapistiyle hakim olursam olayım bunu
kendi ana dilinde birinin sunması benim
sunmam daha anlamlı olur hiçbir şeyin
kaçmasını istemiyorum O dedi ki bizim
alanımızın bir kısmı da ne der
korkuların üzerine gideceksin Peki
tekniklerini size anlatmayacağım ama
esas işimiz Hayat biliyorsunuz
karşılaşmalar buradaki bir karşılaşma
gibi bu karşılaşmalar eşittir bizim
davranışı dediğimiz ekolü belirler
buradan alıp eve götürdüğünüz şey ise
bilissel dediğimiz ekolü belirler Yani
ben söylediğimde birtakım şeyleri
hepiniz farklı şekillerde algılayabilir
isiniz ama ancak algılayabildiğimiz ya
da Benim söylediğimden fazlasını alıp
eve götürürsünüz ben de tabii gözümün
önüne resimler geliyor biliyorsunuz
İnsanlar bir şeyleri düşündükleri Zaman
Yalnızca düşünmezler her düşünülen şeyin
resmini çizer zihin Hatta Melek bile
Dediğiniz zaman melekler insanın Zihnine
bir takım görüntülerle gelir benim de
gözümün önüne şöyle bir görüntü geliyor
kocaman bir amfi Hollanda Burası
Amsterdam ve amfinin içinde ismini hep
kitaplardan okuduğum çok major isimler
ve ben oraya çıkacağım Üstelik görüntüye
göre de 3ün sunucu 3ün sunucu olduğum
için y çok kalabalık bir anfe olacak ve
bütün insanlar orada olacak korkunç bir
heyecan hemen ardından
moderatör şöyle bir şey yaptı Dedi ki
şimdi bu sırada gitmeyeceğiz kimin
ismini okursam o sunacak dedi isimler
okunuyor ve ben içeri girdiğimde salonda
gördüğüm manzara hayallerimden daha da
beter Çünkü hiç gelmeyeceğini umduğum
kişiler de gelmiş hepsinin isimlerini
sadece o yıllarda kitaplardan biliyorum
şimdiyse hepsi dostlarım Hayatta
Kalanlar tabii Ondan sonra ve dedi ki
şimdi bu sıraya göre Benim okuduğum
sıraya göre geleceksiniz düşündüm
matematiksel olarak 20 kişi sunum
yapacak herhalde üten 1E gelme
olasılığım 20'ye düşme ya da aralarda
bir yere düşme olasılığından daha düşük
dolayısıyla biraz rahatladım Sonra
birinci ismi Okudu o geldi sunumunu
yaptı O gitti ikinci 3üncü düncü
gelmiyor benim o sırada Benim aklıma
başka bir şey geldi Şöyle bir arkaya
baktım salon giderek küçülüyor azalıyor
şim burada da azalanlar vardır mutlaka
ve şimdi Bendeki kaygı yer değiştirdi
şöyle düşünmeye başladım ya bu kadar
hazırlandım 2 yıllık bir emeğe 2,5
yıllık bir emeğe 10 dakikada sunacağım
bu kadar yaptım Beni bu kadar az kişimiz
dinleyecek Yani o çarp terleme nefes
darlığı gibi kaygı belirtileri yer
değiştirdi bu kadar az kişiye mi
anlatacağım diye endişeleniyorum ve bir
türlü okumuyor benim ismimi en son bir
baktım arkalarda 78 kişi var bir kişi
konuşuyor Bir de hemen Arkamda biri var
buradaki konuşmacı konuşmasını bitirdi o
8 kişi gitti mi arkamda tek kişi kalmış
döndüm dedim ki beni dinler misin Böyle
bakıyor suratıma dedim ki İngilizce
biliyor musun biliyorum dedi Nerelisin
dedim Yunanlı ded dost komşu vesaire
burayı dinle ifade vermiyor Onun üzerine
dedim ki bak bilmiyorum Holland en güzel
Endonezya restoranları vardır Eğer
burada kalırsan seni buranın en güzel
endoz restoranına götüreceğim Anlıyor
musun beni dedim anlıyorum dedi ben
aşağı inerken Kendi Kendime şunu
söylüyorum dedim ki bak sen bir
profesyonelin bir kişi 1000 kişi bir gün
binlere de anlatacaksın ama önce bir
kişiyi anlat ama bir kişiyi anlatırken
gözlerin içine bak ve sanki bin kişiye
anlatıyormuş gibi hayal et ve o şekilde
ona bakarak onu etkileyecek şekilde o
zaman beden dili falan gibi laflar var
Ben her zaman bu lafları çok tav olmuş
bir adam değilim bence beden diliniz
konuşmanızın içeriğinin önüne geçiyorsa
tatsız bir şeydir içeriktir en önemli
şey Beden diliyle beslersin Neyse ben
bunun gözlerine bakarak anlattım
anlattım ve beni alkışladı o sırada
moderatör bir şey diyor ama ben hiç
duymuyorum ben direkt adamın yanına
gittim Dedim ki Beni dinledin Hadi enden
özyan gidiyoruz H dedi Dedim ki Niye
beğenmedin mi yo Beğendim dedi e dedim
gidelim 20 dakika sonra gideceğiz dedi
Neden dedim son konuşmacı benimdir
dedim Evet şimdi
Dolayısıyla gerçekten o zaman bu zaman
kaç kişinin dinlediği Eee Hiçbir zaman
benim için bir mesele olmadı Önemli
olan bir kişiye Plan anlatsanız bu dünya
için Hiçbirimiz hiçbir şey değiliz ama
her birimiz birileri için bir dünyayız
dolayısıyla böyle baktığımızda
insanların buradan alıp götürdüğü şeyler
yalnızca kendilerine aldıkları değil
çevrelerine de yaydıkları şeyler diye
hep öyle düşünmüşümdür şimdi konumuz bu
eee Erkekler de burada pek inandırıcı
değil gibi geliyor olabiliriz size ama
şöyle söyleyeyim çoğu kez politik
doğruların konuşulduğu bir dünyada kadın
erkek farklılıklarını konuşmak büyük bir
cesaret isem bırakın kadın erkek
farklılıklarını konuşmak kadın erkek
farklılıklarını gündeme getiren bir
zihniyetin bile kolaylıkla ayrımcılıkla
suçlanabilir nedeni nedir biliyor
musunuz cinsiyetlerin eşitliğinin
cinsiyetlerin benzerliğiyle eşter
tutulması Oysa eşit olmak için benzer
olmak zorunda değiliz hele hele
farklılıklarımızla çeşitliliklerimiz le
Büyümek durumunda olduğumuz bir
dünyada şimdi böyle baktığımız zaman bir
başka şey geliyor aklımıza
yani bakın farklılıklar dediğimiz zaman
buradaki farklılıkların içinde
hiçbir üstünlük konotasyon yok yok
cinsiyetlerin birbirinden farklı
olmaları bir Cinsiyetin ötekinden daha
üstün olduğu anlamına hiçbir zaman
gelmiyor bunu fark etmemiz lazım yani
biz farklılık fobisinden çıkıp
farklılıklarla daha varlıklı daha zengin
bir hale gelmemiz gerekirken Biz
maalesef zaman zaman farklılıklar
nedeniyle şiddete kadar sergilenen
birtakım davranış türleri görüyoruz Bu
da bize neyi
düşündürmelidir Belki de şeftalinin
pembe olmasının muzu ürkütmesin
gerçeğini daha iyi anlamamız lazım yani
farklılıklarımızla birlikte
yaşayabilmeyi öğrenmek birleştirmek
kucaklayabilecek
her zaman farklılıklarımızdan daha fazla
ama farklı olmak eşitliğe aykırı bir
kavram asla değil eşitlik Bana
sorarsaniz farklı cinsiyetlerin yapmak
istedikleri seçebilme özgürlüğüdür
farklılık ise bu cinsiyetlerin yani
erkek ve kadının aynı şeyi seçmeme
özgürlüğüdür isterseniz şöyle de
diyebilirsiniz bir restorana gittiğiniz
zaman kadın ve erkek önünüze aynı menü
konuyorsa bu eşitliktir aynı menüden
farklı yiyecekler seçebilmek ise
özgürlüktür bu ise farklılıktır onun
için bu ikisini mutlaka göz önünde
tutmamız lazım eğer biz eşitlikten söz
ediyorsak bunu farklılıklar ya da
benzerlikler üzerine kurmam malıyız Yani
benzerliklerin değil hakların
sorumlulukların kaynak ve imkanların
olanakların eşit sunulması olmalı Eğer
biz eşitlikten söz ediyorsak Şimdi ancak
kaynak ve olanaklar eşit sunulduğu
takdirde farklılık bir Fobi olmaktan
çıkıp daha çok
kucaklanıp bir kavram haline
dönüşebilir kadın erkek eşitliği
unutmayalım ki bir kadın hakları
meselesi değildir İnsan hakları
meselesidir ve konu insan hakları
olduğunda hepimizin elini aynı taşın
altına koyması beklenir bir başka
değişle eşitliğin sağlanması her iki
Cinsiyetin katkılarını gerektirir
Unutmayalım ki hepimiz bir zincir
insanlık zincir ve yine Unutmayalım ki
her zincir yalnızca en çürük hal
güçlüdür Dolayısıyla Eğer bu zinciri
sağlam tutabilmek istiyorsak o zaman ne
yapmamız gerekir yapmamız gereken şey
zincirlerimizi onarmak yıpranmış ya da
isterseniz yıpratılmış dersem olan
halkanın yanında durarak daha anlamlı
birliktelikler
oluşturmaktır kadın erkek rolleri nerede
öğrenilir ilk önce ailede ailede
öğrenildiğine göre o zaman Unutmayalım
ki iyi bir aile olmayı
iyi aile Ben Bu iyi kötü Güzel Çirkin
laflarından uzaklaşalım çok zaman oluyor
çünkü yargı içeriyor Bence her zaman
iyideki kötüyü
kötüdür nektarı nektari zehirle güzeldi
çirkini çirkindeki güzelle birlikte
görmek gerekir Ama iyi herkesin dilinde
olduğu için iyi aile Ne demek bana göre
iyi aile bireysel farklılıklar yanı sıra
ortak amaçlar ve değerler oluşturan
ailelerdir buradan diyeceksiniz ki ne
demek amaç ve değerler Ben ikisi
arasında bir ayrım yapıyorum amaç nedir
amaç Ç kez sonuç yönelimli ve gayretle
elde edilebilen elde edildiği zaman da
önemini kaybeden üstü çizilip Geride
bırakılan
şeylerdir buna karşılık değerler ne
kadar çaba sarf ederseniz sarf edin asla
bütünüyle elde edemeyeceğiniz ama elde
ettiğiniz kadarıyla olduğunuzda da
değerinden hiçbir şey
kaybetmeyen başkalarına ve kendilerimiz
yönelik tutum ve davranışlarımızda
rehber olarak kullandığımız temel
ilkeler bütünüdür Ne demek istiyorsun
diye örnek ver dersen hemen şunu
söyleyelim evlilik bir amaç anlamlı
beraberlik bir Değerdir öğrenen bilen
olmak bilen adam olmak bir amaçtır hep
öğrenen kalmak
Değerdir sağ kalın bir amaçtır onurlu
bir yaşam sürdürebilmek bir Değerdir
acıdan kaçmak bir amaçtır acı çekmeye
değer bir yaşam öyküsü oluşturabilmek
ise bir Değerdir Onun için amaçlarla
değer birbirinden ayrıştırmak ve
seçimlerinizi yaparken Şu soruyu
sormanız beklenir Bu yaptığım seçim
sadece dezavantaj avantajları açısından
değil Çünkü iş dünyası değil bu neyi
düşünmeliyim Ben böyle karar veriyorum
bu bu kararı verdiğimden ve hayatımı çok
kolaylaştı bir karar verirken Çünkü her
zaman avantaj dezavantajlar birbirine
çok uzak olmayabilir karar verirken
nasıl veriyorum görüyor musunuz hep
şöyle bu aldığım karar beni olmak
istediğim bene yakınlaştırıyor mu
uzaklaştırıyor yakınlaştırıyor karar
almak çok kolay çünkü Bir ben var bir de
olmak istediğim ben var olmak istediğim
beni 15 yaşındayken 25 yaşında olurum
zannetmiştim 25'e geldim Olmadı Sonra
35'te olurum zannettim 35 oldu Gene
olmadı sonra 45 45 oldu Gene olmadı
anladım ki olmak istediğim benana asla
ulaşamayacaksın olsa olsa ancak bir
yolculuk yapabilirsin ve bu yolculuğun
içinde duruyor olmanın kendisi güzel
Zaten onun için de amaç ve değerleri
birbirinden ayırt etmemiz ve öle
yaşamayı öğrenmemiz lazım lazım önemli
değerlerden bir tanesi de geleneksel
kadın erkek klişelerini rollerini
demeyelim de klişelerini esnetmek ve
çocuklarımızı daha Adil kapsayıcı ve
eşitlikçi bir kültür içinde büyütmek en
önemli şeylerden bir tanesi bu kadın ve
erkek lorinin nesilden nesile
aktarılamıyor bir tanesi nedir Bir
tanesi kendi ailemizden hayatın bize
öğrettikleri Hayat hepimize aynı
cömertlikte davranmıyor kimilerimiz daha
cimri kimilerimiz çok daha Cömert
Dolayısıyla insanlar hayatlarının Mimar
dedikleri zaman bana insanlara haksızlık
yapıldığını düşünüyorum Çünkü bu mimarin
tamamı bize ait değil Hayat Belki de bu
doğumla ölüm arasına sıkıştırılmış ve
Adı Hayat konmuş zaman
dilimi her birimize her birimize
istisnasız hiçbir Bedel ödemeden
verilmiş en büyük armağandır ama hayat
olayları değil Hayat olaylarının Adil
olduğunu söylemek herhalde çok mümkün
değildir söylersem de inandırıcı
olmayacağını biliyorum ama k eler de
bizim biçimler imizi belirliyor klişeler
neler kadın ağır başlı
olmalıdır erkek güçlü olmalıdır Erkekler
Ağlamaz şimdi buradan Şu soruyu sormak
istiyorum sizleri ne Ağlatır ne Ağlatır
ağlamak ne anlama gelir bir tedavi
oturumunda karı kocayı birlikte
görüyorum ağlayan karısının gözyaşlarına
son derece duyarsız olan bir adam
dönüyor bana diyor ki bakın Doktor bey
gene Ağlıyor diyor işte diyor çok zayıf
hep böyle Bunu söylemekle de yetinmiyor
üstüne üstük bir de
böbürlenen Hayatım boyunca hiç ağlamadım
Ben de dönüp diyorum ki biliyor musunuz
Sizin için çok üzüldüm dönüyor herhalde
karım için üzülmüş olmalısınız ağlayan O
diyor Hayır diyorum sizin için üzüldü
benim için Üzülmeyin karım için üzülün
diyor Ben de dönüp diyorum ki Müsaade
ederseniz kimin için üzüleceğim ben
karar vermek istiyorum O da diyor ki
Peki niçin benim için üzüldünüz Çünkü
dedim Siz 55 yaşında bir erkeksiniz ve
55 yaşında bir adamın hayatı boyunca
ağlayacak kadar değerli bulduğu hiçbir
şey olmaması çok acı vericidir Onun için
sizin için
üzüyorum gerçekten ağlamak artık orada
olmayanın değerini gösteririz yani
ağladığınız zaman artık o yoktur
değerini görürsün Bazı şeylerin değeri
ne yazık ki onları kaybettiğimiz zaman
anlaşılmaktadır onun için de biz biraz
da ölü sever yaşıyoruz Yani öldükten
sonra herkes çok iyi ölmeden evvel
alkışlasın güzel olan bu olurdu toplumun
erkeğe atfettiği roller babalığı nasıl
etkiliyor farklı kültürde bile olsa
babalar arasındaki benzerlikler
enteresan bir şekilde farklılıklardan
daha fazla bazı roller babaların üstüne
yapıştırılmış gibi ne gibi koruyuculuk
Finans saygınlık ağırlığı korumak
disiplin sağlamak yola sokmak güvenlik
sağlamak gibi görevler dikkat ederseniz
bakım verme konusunda babanın çok az
rolü var Ne var ki çocuklar
ebeveynlerden beklentilerini ebeveynin
cinsiyetine göre belirlemiyor Onlar
babalarından da çok şey bekliyor ve
özellikle babaları büyüme ve
gelişmelerinde aktif olarak yer
aldıklarında çocuklar daha sağlıklı ve
mutlu çocuklar olarak büyüyorlar Şimdi
başka bir babalık mümkün mü bildiğimiz
olabilmeli olmalı Peki başka bir babalık
biçimi Bu bağlamda Neyi gerektiriyor tek
şapkalı rolden çok şapkalı bir role çek
geçişi gerektiriyor Aynı zamanda da
babalık kavramını sosyopolitik gündemde
giderek yükselen bir değer haline
getirmeyi gerektiriyor Peki nedir bu
yani babalık yalnızca evin güvenliğini
ve gelirini sağlamak gibi algılandığında
bunu sağlayamayan erkeğe duyulan saygı
azalıyor otoriteyi korumak adına çocuk
ile rahat sızacak samimi ilişki içine
girememek ise babanın kaçırdığı en büyük
şey duygularını dile getirememek Peki
benim anladığım yeni babalık anlayışı ne
öğretirken domine
etme çocuğunu ilişki kurarken bilen adam
rolünden çıkıp onla birlikte öğrenen
adam rolüne geçmek anlatan konuşan değil
dinleyen ve birlikte bir şeyler yapan
bir babalık caydıran değil
cesaretlendiren bir babalık başarısızlık
diye düşünmeyip başarıdan öğrenen bir
çocuğum var başarısızlıktan diye
Unutmayın ki bazen başarısızlık
başarıdan çok daha cömerttir bu biraz
evvel yapboz parçaları dünyayı bir araya
getirme örneği verildi küçük çocuğun
eline yapboz veriyorsunuz ve Bir saatten
beri yapmak istediği şeyi yapamıyor
bitiremiyor bu çocuk başarısız mıdır
yoksa öğrenen çocuk mu bu kısmı sizi
bırakıyor Yani siz kendiniz düşünün
nasıl isterseniz reddeden eleştiren
değil kabul eden bir babalık kabul etmek
onaylamak demek değil kabul edmek olanı
olmasını görmek istediğimiz gibi
görmekten vazgeçip olduğu gibi
görebilmek demek Yoksa boyun eğmek demek
değil başka katı yerine esnekliği
öğreten Çünkü bu hayatın içinde en büyük
patolojiler kılıktan gelir
ruhsal olanlarda fiziksel olanlarda
sorumluluklarla haklar arasında denge
kurabilen çocuğunu ve eşini kim ve ne
olduğu için değil kim ve ne olduğuna
rağmen sevebilen bir babalık hepsinden
önemlisi de şefkat şefkat merhamet
anlamında değil Şefkat insan Acılarına
duyarlılık ve bu acıyı azaltmak
doğrultusunda çaba sarf edebilmek demek
çocuklarla birlikte var olabilmek
onlarla birlikte çaba sarf edebilmek
demek Dolayısıyla şunu söyleyerek
bitirmek istiyorum bakın dikkat edilmesi
gereken konular insan haklarına koşulsuz
saygı kadının güçlendirilmesi lafı çok
güzel bir lafta sizi kutlarım onun için
güçlendirilmesi değil Ben tabii ki
bireysel anlamda konuşmuyorum insanlık
anlamında yani ona hak ettiği yeri
verebilmek ona hak ettiği şeyi
verebilmek bizim kimseyi güçlendirmek
güçlendirme kelimesi üstten bir bakış
Aynen Merhamet gibi yukarıdan bir bakış
Oysa Şefkat eşitlerin ilişkisi Burada da
bu güçlendirme lafını düzeltmek
istiyorum kadın görünebilir liğini
artıracak liderliğine olanak verecek
koşulları buna erkek sağlasın demiyor
hep birlikte güçlendirme hareketinin de
sadece erkeklerin meselesi olmadığın
kadınların birbirleriyle iyi bir zincir
kurabilmeleri önemi cinsiyetler arasında
eşitliğin bireysel Ailesel ve toplumsal
yararlarını anlamak ve bunun cinsiyetten
bağımsız bir sosyal sorumluluk olarak
görebilmek cinsiyetlerin savaşından
kazanılacak hiçbir şey yok Bana
sorarsanız kavga bir kez başladığında
Kazanan taraf yoktur Sadece kaybetmenin
dereceleri vardır yani kazanan bir taraf
yoktur kadınlar için unutulmaması
gereken şey erkeklere şans vermek bütün
bakın söylemek zorundayım en iyi erkek
ölü erkektir lafından vazgeçin varsa
kafanızda birkaç tane iyi adam var a few
Goodman derler birkaç tane iyi adam
yanlarınız oturanlar sevdiğiniz insanlar
gibi en iyi erkek ölü erkektir
mantığından Bir çıkalım ikincisi bilgi
beceri artırma biraz da cesaretlendirme
aracıyla dayanışmada yer alacak ve
kadınların yanında olacak birçok erkek
olacağını görmek babalık ve duyarlı bir
erkeklik algısını arttırmak için gönüllü
eğitimler verebilmek erkekler için
önemli hatırlatma bu erkekler için
önemli hatırlat dayanışma sağlamaya
çalışırken adı dayanışma bakın
güçlendirme değil çalışırken dualarının
soru işareti doğamız diyorlar ya Efendim
doğam da böyle Ulan sen bütün doğayı
değiştirdin kendi doğana gelince Benim
doğam değişmiyor doğalar gereği
hareketin lideri olmak gibi bir hisse
kapılmamak kadın hareketlerin lideri
kadındır Ama siz dayanışmanın bir
parçasısın O kadar insan olarak destek
olmakla idareyi ele almak arasındaki
farkları iyi bilmek sonuç Bir ülkenin
özgürleşmesi ancak tüm bireylerin ve
özellikle kadınların özgürleşmesi ile
ilgilidir ve Unutmayalım ki zayıfmış
gibi davranmaktan yorulmuş her güçlü
kadına karşın güçlüymüş gibi
davranmaktan yorulmuş bir erkek
vardır aptal taklit yapmaktan sıkılmış
her kadına karşın ın sesi gibi davranmak
zorunda kalmış birçok erkek vardır
uzatmayacağım R konuşması bir şunu
söyleyeceğim Sonuç olarak erkek ve kadın
Bir kuşun iki kanadı gibidir ve bu iki
kanat benzer şekilde gelişmede insan
türü asla uçamayacak saygılarım
hepinize